it began as a military operation now
though it's a massive onslaught on the
well-being indeed the lives of countless
innocent civilians
residential areas have been raised to
the ground many people killed in their
own homes families divided hundreds of
thousands of mostly women and children
forced to leave the country how many
will never return it's impossible to say
and the worst could still be yet to come
so on another special edition of to the
point we ask putin's war no mercy for
civilians
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much for joining us and
my guests here in the studio and in bonn
are jessica berlin who has a
german-american background and is a
security and geopolitics expert also
with us is maximilian pop from the
influential german news weekly spiegel
and a warm welcome to to mikhail
bashueyev from dw's russian department
who joins us as i said from bonn
thank you all three for being with me
here today and i'd like to begin with
you jessica this is an increasingly ugly
walk can there be any doubt that this is
now going to have a huge impact on the
whole of the european continent
well this is the worst human
humanitarian crisis we have seen on this
continent since world war ii
we've had already just in the last less
than two weeks over two million
two million ukrainians have fled the
country it's a nightmare number and it's
an it's an unbelievable number it's
truly truly cannot be overstated the the
impact of this crisis okay
let's listen in uh before we really get
going to how ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky has been responding to
the latest developments
we will not forgive the shooting of
unarmed people
the destruction of our infrastructure
we won't forgive hundreds and hundreds
of victims
thousands and thousands of sufferings
and god won't forgive
not today
not tomorrow
never mind
[Music]
maximilian pop that is uh that was a
very angry outburst there by the
ukrainian president you've spent a lot
of time out in the field as a reporter
compare what we're seeing now in ukraine
with anything that you've seen in the
past i have no comparison you have no
comparison no comparison as
jessica said i mean this is
unmatched in in recent history and and
and what i'm afraid is the worst is yet
to come
i mean we are we are seeing that the
shelling has started yeah and it's just
gonna intensify the more putin gets
under pressure the
the worse the war gets for him
and they are moving slow at the moment
the more i think he will upscale the
attacks so yeah i'm very i'm very
worried
okay well as a result of the fighting
huge numbers of people have left the
country many heading initially for
poland which is ukraine's immediate
neighbour it's already clear that more
will follow the majority of them women
and children
we are going to look for work because i
need to provide for my children and my
husband stayed to defend his country
it's dangerous there people are shooting
i have a child
fighter jets are flying around houses
are exploding it's terrible so
frightening
we didn't want to leave it was so
painful but we did it because of the
children i didn't want to leave ukraine
we love our country we have such a
beautiful country great people
it hurts so much
it's so hard
my heart is still there
it's so hard to see that children are
being bombed every day
we just want peace
shocking statements there uh
jessica as i was listening to what we
were hearing i was writing down fear
desperation pain hopelessness and i know
that you have been down to the central
station here in berlin and collected
your own firsthand impressions
of what's going on give us those
impressions well right now um the lower
levels of berlin central station has
basically been turned into a crisis
response center
every day over 12 000 ukrainian refugees
are arriving in
berlin halpenhof and
they arrive are unloaded from the trains
and there are basically hundreds of
volunteers who are distributing food and
water um also arranging housing
a ukrainian couple from hakib is now
staying in the little little work room
in in my flat
with with my husband and me and it's
just really um it's heart-rending the
despair the exhaustion the fear the
disorientation of these people um this
is not this is not what they would have
expected this is not what was going to
happen next in their lives of course not
i
it's
just like for any syrians or afghans or
people fleeing violence um anywhere else
in the world in the past years um i
think this is the the great shock in
europe for so long we have thought
this doesn't happen here anymore after
world war ii we learned our lesson and
oh that and the balkans well that was
the balkans but we here in northern
europe this doesn't happen here and what
this crisis uh
i hope is driving home to everyone in
europe now
war is never that far away
and war in europe is not that long ago
let me just pick up on one point that i
mentioned that uh most of the people who
are on the move here are women and
children yes that's been much talked
about what what are your impressions
about what that signifies
well the basic answer for that is that
um men from the age of 18 to 60 um are
now legally barred from leaving ukraine
um in case they need to be drafted to
serve in the ukrainian army uh many men
of all ages have already signed up and
others are supporting in logistics and
humanitarian relief on the ground in
ukraine
but they are all basically in readiness
waiting um for potentially being drafted
maximilian the uh the eu says it will
effectively take in all refugees fleeing
the war in ukraine do you think it can
cope do you think germany can cope well
it's a it's a it's a remarkable step
given how the policy has been in recent
years i mean we had a comparable
situation in 2015 when many syrians were
escaping to europe and there was a huge
outcry especially from the
from the right
mass demonstrations against refugees and
so on
and now it's like it's like this new
welcoming culture even in countries like
like poland and hungary let me say i
think that's great
it's necessary and it's an act of
solidarity
i wish
it would be it would be similar be the
same it should be the same to people
fleeing from you mention it afghanistan
syria i mean remember they think back
last last november when people read the
belarusian
polish border what happened there i mean
they were tear gassed
they were they were kept out in the cold
freezing in the in the forest so there's
some discrepancy here which i personally
find
a bit
distressing
but the solidarity that is that is shown
now is is remarkable and what is
important is to build up on that
and don't do the same mistakes like in
2015 when you were like letting people
in but don't didn't provide the
necessary infrastructure so that is what
has to happen now fast have the
infrastructure get them into the labor
market help with the integration and and
prepare for them to stay longer don't
expect that they will go back like in a
month or two because i don't think
that's a
realistic scenario okay an important
message let's go to mikko in mikhail
bond just yeah thanks for thanks for
waiting
uh i i just like to begin with your
person here a little bit your background
mikhail you were born in russia
but actually quite close to the border
with ukraine and i know that's important
for you that proximity and now you're
sitting where you are in bomb we're here
in berlin and you're witnessing the
biggest movement uh the biggest exodus
from a country since world war ii what's
your reaction
well first of all my heart is broken um
and i'm trying not to get too personal
or too emotional on this but what we see
is two tragedies the first the primary
tragedy is the war that's happening uh
in the ukraine
uh driven by
the invasion of russian military forces
the
it's it's unbelievable and and it was
unthinkable
until last november and then
um
much of us uh saw it coming and could
not prevent it coming
but
my heart is is obviously also with
the secondary tragedy tragedy which is
um
unfolding
collapse of russian economy russian
society disintegration
of um
of the russian society that's
interesting that you say that because
that was precisely my next question that
this is you know everybody's focusing on
ukraine rightly so
this is where you know
you know the the awful things in the
main are happening at this point in time
but two countries ukraine and russia
face
terrible times or difficult very very
difficult times ahead including russia
absolutely we have to focus on on the
situation in
ukraine and help refugees
um coming from there but also
we have to think two steps ahead and
these two steps are
really disintegrating in a in a in a
really
fast fashion disintegration of russia
with the global order
um
we had jokes in russia that you know
some measures uh by kremlin are
greatly um doing a north korea of sorts
out of russia but no it's not a metaphor
it's not a joke
uh russia is cutting
uh so many uh roots and so many
connections to the outer world um it's
something that we have to to have in
mind how to live with a huge country
that is hostile basically
and that can inflict much pain
not only on
uh the neighboring countries okay thank
you very much for that perspective there
michael from uh from bonn the former
german capital uh jessica you are also a
geopolitical expert as uh as i mentioned
and uh i'd just like to bring up some
some images of the destruction that's
been taking place in the ukraine and
while we're looking at those images i
wonder whether you could tell us whether
you think
the ukraine can win its battle or can
survive its battle for freedom
jessica so it's not an entrepreneur
well
what we're seeing
in ukraine right now uh this is only the
beginning unfortunately yeah it's been
not even two weeks since the invasion
started
and whether or not ukraine can survive
can hold out against the russian
military
and the increasing use of indiscriminate
bombing and artillery as vladimir putin
as we were discussing earlier
has been increasingly pressured and
pushed into a corner his original
strategy for this invasion has failed
that's clear and now
he's going to be more desperate he's
going to use more firepower because he
cannot afford in his view to lose or to
be seen as having lost so the only way
ukraine will survive this is with
increased support military support from
the west
air support or the contribution at the
very least of jets of fighter planes to
ukraine for ukrainian pilots to pilot if
the west is not willing to take that
step um and above all we need to stop
financing the war for russia with our
oil and gas imports here in europe and
in particular here in germany and just
yesterday olaf schultz announced and
made very clear that the german
chancellor chavez has made very clear
that he's not willing to take that step
that we're too dependent on russian
energy
but the cost
the cost of letting this war continue
and of financing russia's war on ukraine
through our energy purchases is going to
be much higher
than any cost of cutting off russian oil
and gas imports absolutely there's so
much i can only support jessica if i may
peter if i may support jessica and say
let's think about
what jessica said in a kind of game
theory
i think
the west
should gamble with a cut of oil and gas
inputs from russia
as as long as we you know
the west is uh is having much more
resources to
hold out
while russia is not
you know so the uh russia cannot afford
uh to
er
you know russia hasn't got that much
time
and we have to have this in mind
maximilian the time is is on the on the
on the ukrainian and western side that's
that's the point i i partly agree i
wanted to add one thing if we remember
what putin has been doing already in
syria
where the russian air force was flying
deliberate attacks against schools
against hospitals
then re-attacking people who who rushed
to help
and i'm i'm very much concerned that
he's going to repeat a very very similar
strategy now in in in ukraine and cities
like kiev exactly
so i think before the the war
ends i'm afraid it's getting much more
brutal yeah and um and yeah yeah
we've seen it before what he did in
chechnya what he did in syria he'll do
it again in ukraine i have no doubt
we're talking about to get proactive you
know that's what i'm talking about we
have to get proactive in this
confrontation
i mean the west
we have to get proactive we have to
intervene we have to save lives but at
the at the same time you know that it's
it's not easy to say that by any manner
it means nothing is easy well it's easy
to say but hard to do
but that's the point i mean then the
other side will say but this could lead
to world war three
we are already
at a tipping point risking world war
three
no
our action and our i don't want to
believe what you're saying well neither
do i
but unfortunately as a
student of history
um and as a geopolitical expert we are
truly at a tipping point
vladimir putin ultimately and the elites
around him
the oligarchs and the security elites
surrounding the kremlin they have the
most power right now to
save this situation but
if they do not act if they are not able
to neutralize the threat to world peace
that vladimir putin currently presents
and we cannot count on them to do that
we cannot assume that they are going to
fix this themselves then the west does
need to act vladimir putin has already
said he considers western sanctions
the extreme sanctions that we've put
through he considers this an act of war
he's already using the language to give
him an excuse to attack
nato
and so it brings me no pleasure to to
say
that we already stand potentially on the
brink of a of a devastating war within
europe that would have vast consequences
around the world thus a potential world
war three
this is not melodrama unfortunately this
is the risk we face so
uh one cornerstone of what you're saying
really is i mean vladimir zelinsky the
the ukrainian leader came out and said
if ukraine does not survive the whole of
europe will not survive so ukraine
cannot lose this war
well to some extent yes ukraine is is
fighting for europe in general yeah and
uh but the thing is i would be very
cautious
i very much support
that the west the european countries the
us are supporting ukraine as much as
they can sending weapons having heavy
sanctions especially against putin and
his regime not against russia and its
people because i want to say one thing
this is putin's war not russia's war and
i think it's it's very important to make
this
distinction so we should be
very supportive to to ukraine
but i would be very cautious
for the nato to get involved in this so
if we um discuss for example about a
no-fly zone i think that is a very
dangerous thing because yes we are in a
in
a very problematic confrontation already
with russia
but they we are not in a third world war
yet and that has to be prevented a
nuclear war has to be prevented and any
direct
involvement of nato i think could easily
trigger things that then get out of
control very fast so i would say
everything short to war but not entering
the war is nato um directly we're
talking about a dreadful
oh peter i would i would like to add
something
to what maximilian said
and
i agree with him that the no-fly zone
over ukraine is potentially provoking
but cutting of oil and gas imports
is
actually not not in military terms
so it's a better option it costs us
more in the short term but um it would
bring us more in the long term jessica
agreed this is a very simple and clear
action we could do that would cut off
financing to russia's war and i also
agree with maximilian germany is so very
very vulnerable there
if we're not ready to pay higher
energy prices here at home to protect
freedom in europe germany has made
itself absolutely
freedom in europe
if we're not willing
yeah if we're not willing
to pay more for our energy costs and
consumption
to defend peace in europe
then we will lose peace in europe
we can't have it both ways
and the german government needs to have
this conversation with the german people
and make the people understand who have
lived for decades now in peace and
prosperity
we need to have this conversation with
the german people we need to understand
that ukraine's freedom
is our freedom
shocking things are happening uh
dreadful deeds are plenty uh one
question perhaps that arises is the
question of accountability and uh
tony blinken the u.s secretary of state
has been making clear that the world is
keeping a very firm eye on what russian
forces are doing and what consequences
there might be
we've certainly seen uh in the past that
one of russia's methods of war uh is
to be absolutely brutal we're looking
very closely at uh what's happening in
ukraine right now
including what's happening to uh to
civilians
uh we're taking account of it we're
documenting it and we want to ensure
among other things
that there's accountability for it
[Music]
mikko what can you tell us i'm not sure
about the the growing sense in russia
perhaps
that there might be accountability there
might be a day of reckoning that lies
ahead and that the price might be very
high for people in russia especially
military commanders
well this message is not
uh is not spread over russia so let's be
very skeptical about that
um i mean we have to realize and to
spread the word about how effective
russia has been on domestic front
we saw that basically ukraine won this
info war and that
that putin miscalculated his military
operation
but what
we underestimated or overestimated is
how our people in russia would oppose
this war i mean in in the narrative in
russia there is no war people people i i
would have to say sorry sorry
the word that comes to mind for me is
that people in russia many many people
are in denial and they're in more
there's more denial with every day that
that passes
absolutely people don't believe the news
uh coming from their relatives in
ukraine living there and telling about
sheltering and bombing etc they just
don't believe
they believe what they are told in the
russian state-run media
okay um and there is uh either no war or
uh uh only bombing of military
infrastructure etc so a lot of myths and
lies spread um
and this narrative is really effective
this must be recognized here so the
russian population will get this
information and let's hear what jessica
has to say on this one uh our members of
the russian forces senior commanders
likely to be brought to justice at some
stage is that a realistic
possibility i think it's highly unlikely
international justice moves very slowly
even the best of terms
and even if they're indicted in absentia
the likelihood that they would actually
be able to be brought to physically
stand trial
is unlikely but frankly at this point
worrying about the accountability in the
long-term future for the crimes of today
while they're still ongoing must be a
secondary thought the first priority in
focus must be ending this war this
aggression started in moscow and the
quickest way to end it also must come
from moscow the russian people
protesting and the elites around the
kremlin intervening behind closed doors
to find a negotiated
ceasefire and solution they can keep
some billions in exchange for stopping
this war and those discussions are are
going on
as we speak um let's see what happens
what's your turn
who or what can stop vladimir putin at
this stage well let me let me add that i
agree i still think it has a symbolic
meaning because we finally are calling
putin what he is a war criminal he has
been a war criminal in syria
and he's a war criminal now
and it's it's important to name it
i agree i think like international
justice is slow and conflicted
nonetheless
i i find it important that blink and
others
are bringing it up
what ends the war
at this point i don't have a real answer
i don't i don't see that the wise voices
suggest that the the that it would be
possibly the chinese who might
be most likely to have somehow influence
when they whisper in vladimir putin's
ear
some say so others say erdogan i think
that shows how desperate the situation
is i i don't see like a huge
chinese interest to to get very much
involved
in that it's not their war
so i don't have high hopes there um i
don't see that the point for
negotiations has arrived already i mean
if if if this war goes on and on maybe
putin reaches a point where he says
i have to end it one way or the other
and start negotiating but i mean the
price for that is super high
i mean i think he expected that he would
like go in and within a week kiev would
have been fall zelensky would have been
out and he would have taken over it went
another way and everything now is super
unpredictable
super unpredictable the nightmare goes
on i'm afraid
putin's war no mercy for civilians
that's what we've been discussing on to
the point this time round thanks very
much for joining us i hope we've given
you some food for thought in these
difficult times
for now bye bye and show us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you